foreign
[Music]
I hope you're all rested ate lunch so a
couple of sessions and you're ready for
the highlight of the day which is
talking about database migrations the
topic that everyone loves so my name is
I'm the product manager for the database
migration service with me I have Carrie
from Google Cloud
Blackwell team and Gareth from HSBC
so I attended a few sessions and
especially in the databases Trek I see
many many Innovations right Cloud SQL
Enterprise Plus you have MySQL postgres
SQL server lodb with alodb AI you have
spannel data boost all of those like
great offerings that we have you need to
build a bridge to get to those places
this is exactly what we're doing what
we're going to talk about is migration
so how you we're getting there and now
we're helping you together
so why customers are moving to the cloud
we're at Cloud next I think that most of
you know why people are coming to the
cloud but just like a general highlight
and specifically in databases so first
no one wants to manage the database no
one wants to manage infrastructure it
takes time it takes budget you're always
concerned to wake you up in the middle
of the night thinking about maintenance
and upgrades when you're moving to the
cloud and especially in managed you know
database offering you're getting greed
of all of that you're getting the entire
budget that you used to
spend on teams on your databases on
servers and now this entire budget or
most of this budget is vacant you can
you know spend it on your business on
your new customer experience the second
is that only the cloud can offer like
globally scalable performance available
services so if you would try to build it
on your own it would be very very hard
in the cloud we offer databases for
example spanner is a good example that
are as available performance so this is
like the two main motivations and if I'm
you know digging a little bit deeper
into database migrations what we see is
the three types of Journeys to the cloud
again if you ever did a database
migration this seems to be familiar the
first one is the migrate Journey this is
the basic lift and shift so if a
customer that is MySQL postgres SQL
server and just want to move to the same
flavor in the cloud so I mean my SQL
customer I move into Cloud support my
SQL I mean pause Grace moving to Classic
for possess or hello DB for postgres SQL
Server the same the expectation from
customers is one click right they don't
need to worry about anything else
they're not re-platforming they don't
need to translate anything and the
expectation is that giving one click and
I'm there I'm in Cloud SQL
the second type of Journey is the
modernized journey this is the journey
where it's much more complex but still
it's just a matter of translating your
Source language to destination language
I mean a proprietary Legacy Oracle
database and I want to move to like open
source postgres lodb whatever in the
cloud but I'm changing you know the
engines this is more complex but I'm not
going into the platforming right I don't
want to change my application relay all
I want to do is just go from one engine
to another engine again not an easy task
but definitely doable and the third type
of Journey is the transform Journey this
is where you're moving to a cloud native
database already mentioned this panel so
think about all the possibilities that
spanner can offer you with the global
available Global scalable scalable
performant and now basically you would
want to reply from your application
because what you want to do you want to
basically take this amazing
probabilities of the database and just
create new experiences and offering for
your customers so those are the three
Journeys today in the session we're
going to focus on the modernized journey
so already mentioned a bit but
migrations are complex I know that
personally I don't like changes even
thinking about moving a house or moving
an apartment from you know to Next Door
makes me anxious I know that like moving
your data from one place to another
place is extremely challenging
especially in the heterogeneous or
modernized Journey migrations are
complex there are dependencies people
always think about migration database
migration is like you know a DBA sitting
in the dark and just like clicking three
clicks and that's it
it's never the case there is always a
networking team application team CIO CFO
to the total cost how much time did it
take you need to plan so especially
introduce migration there is
organizational complexity within because
there is an organizational complexity
it's time consuming we saw migrations
that start and end in a mean migration
in the entire process not just like the
clicks part the process of you know
advocating for migration and then until
the point that the database is on the
other side we saw processes that it
takes a day we saw project it takes
heels you need to get the Intel
organization on board
the second thing that you need to move
the data in a reliable way no one wants
to lose data while they're migrating and
this is exactly one of the risks by
customers are super anxious about it
they want to make sure that when they
are moving from one part from the source
to the Target they're not losing any
data and the lifeline of the business
the data stays as is
so after you know I make you anxious
about that Miser migrations I want to
show you how we address database
migrations
in Google Cloud so we invest in like
three pillars the first is product
this is what I represent we are
investing to build and I believe that we
are building the best migration product
in the market we want the migration
first of all to be simple intuitive
straightforward we don't want you to do
anything that you're not you don't need
to do right so we're trying to build and
I believe that we are building the best
product in the market we do realize
though the difference will be the
perfect product let's say that I'm
building the perfect product there is
still a room for expertise and this is
exactly why Kerry is here you still need
the nudge and you need the team that
made you know thousands of migrations
with multiple customers to give it the
right nudge around how you plan the
migration again this is not an easy
process and this is exactly why the
expertise is in Kerry would address it
later on and the funding so we're giving
the right incentives to move to the
cloud so those are the three pillars and
as I was as I promised let's start with
the product so the product is database
migration service we're a native
migration tuning for databases we are a
One-Stop shop for your database
migrations when I say One-Stop shop
means that you starting your migration
in DMS and you're ending then in DMS if
you ever used DMS you know that it's
super simple you have a lot of things
that you're not expecting from a service
to have for example baked in
configuration support lots of in-product
documentations lots of validation so as
a user of migrations in the past
the one thing that was super frustrating
for me was that I started a migration or
any kind of application I hit start and
then two days after it would fail or
there was some configuration I don't
know that it would take 30 minutes for
it to fail we allow to test everything
before we actually start the migration
so we're letting you know that you're in
the right path all the time we're
serverless that means that you're not
you're not responsible for the actual
migration you're responsible for
configuring everything on the source
correctly or the destination but we are
serverless you're not maintaining any
servers you're not paying for any
servers and it auto scales with your
data in addition for every use case that
you're supporting we're supporting
minimal downtown migration so like zero
disruption or close to zero disruption
uh to replication which again for most
customers this is like the number one
priority and with competitive and secure
we are a Google product you would expect
Google product to be compatible and
secure on our end is of course all the
security that you're familiar with but
in addition we are allowing you to
migrate on top of private connectivity
the way that you want to migrate
so
I will talk about about the offering and
what we support today and then we'll
dive into heterogeneous migration or the
modernize so MySQL postgres to Classic
my second postgres was the first use
case that we supported it's been a while
it's uh it's been out a while it's NGA
available for all no additional costs
back City the way that we're addressing
homogeneous migration is that the most
reliable way to migrate is using native
technology of the engine itself we don't
need the Black Box we don't need any
like proprietary
mechanism in order to move the data the
most reliable way would be using the
native replication technology this is
what we do MySQL with postgres it's a
post minimal downtown migration and it
utilizes native replication one metric
that I'm extremely proud of is that more
than 85 percent of the migration are
underway in less than an hour when I say
underway it means that from the moment
that the customer is set or user set and
it starts using DMS to the point of the
migration is running more than 55 of the
cases if they can take them less than an
hour it means that there is no like long
pre-configuration it's very clear what
you need to do again you're extremely
proud
and if you liked possible SQL migrations
to Cloud 6 for postgres you would love
postgresql to ldb for postgres it's
basically the same thing right ledb is
you know postgres highly performant
pause us Enterprise class workloads and
the same way that you're doing that in
postgres to classical process you're
doing postgres to lodb for postgres we
see a huge demand for lldb and DMS meets
you there and helps you do that again
super easy
um it's in GA as well by the release GI
a couple of months ago and it does
utilize native application technology
and I'm extremely excited to see that
I'm excited to announce that we're now
GA for our Oracle to post recipient
migration the modernized journey it
means that you can start doing
modernization and get out of like the
Oracle proprietary database and move to
the you know classic for postgres or to
other postgres today so we'll again
serverless and we help you to reduce the
cost of this like Oracle licenses and in
addition the main thing that I want to
announce today is that we are
introducing code and schema conversion
within the MS I mentioned One-Stop shop
but this is exactly what I mean you're
not using multiple tools you're not
using one tool to do coding schema one
tool to do data migration and then you
need to you know think if it will work
together everything is baked into DMS so
we have integrated coded schema
conversion into DMS we have a seamless
transition between the conversion and
the data movement reality empowered by
compiler walks under the hood so compile
box is an amazing technology that does
conference relation is actually being
used in bigquery migrations as well it's
powered by duet AI I don't know if you
heard about something that's called AI I
think couple of sessions mentioned it
but in the boat in Thomas session in ND
keynote yesterday we are using duet AI
why how are we using duetoi so we do
understand that you can never have 100
automatically conversion of your source
and your code right every code has the
out of the developer the automatic tool
might be hard for them to like to
understand what's going on so when you
walk on DMS and when you update the code
for places that we weren't able to
convert DMS learns and you know and
takes llm
models in order to understand places
that they can extrapolate the code that
is in in other places which basically
means we're saving you a lot of time
instead of doing that 3000 times you're
doing that once twice and that's it with
flexible simple intuitive and
predictable but again this is just words
let me show you a demo
so before I'm going into the demo a
reminder again if you're a DMS unit is
there you are familiar with that but if
not so we have resources in DMS we have
connection profile that presents the
connection to the source and the target
we have
a private connectivity that represents
how we are connected to the source on
top of private connectivity we have the
conversion workspace again this is the
new thing that we that we added that is
the playground for everything related to
code and schema conversion this will I
will focus today and we have a migration
job that takes the connection profile a
conversion workspace private
connectivity getting all together all
those resources are reusable across
multiple migration jobs so you can
configure it once and then just reuse it
super simple
now let's hope that the demo will work
okay
I would start with creating a conversion
workspace so a conversion workspace on
my playground schema code conversion I
will add couple of details to it and
instantly I will see all the
pre-configuration that I need to do on
my Oracle source and my postgres again
in product documentation you don't need
to go to external documentation
everything is within the product
after I'm doing that the next step
obviously would be to Define
the connection to the source in this
case I already have a connection profile
that I can use so I will
I will click it and then the next step
would be the DMS pulls the entire Source
objects from The Source not only tables
not only like that objects we do pull
views stop procedures functions
constraints indexes and we rely you to
flexibility to choose where you want to
start the conversion with we heard
customers saying I don't want everything
I just want to start let's say how do I
want to analyze how you convert my stop
procedure and this is exactly where you
do that I'm going to choose here tables
functions views and so procedures I'm
going to click next and DMS will
automatically convert all of those
objects and I would land into the very
cool honestly a conversion workspace
editor so let's click convert and
continue and this is the main playground
the conversion workspace where I can see
my source and all conversion issue
issues and statuses and in addition if I
would click on the top and you can see
that I can see my postgres SQL classical
process SQL tree which is how DMS
converted my Oracle Source The Next Step
would be to analyze my statuses so there
are three type of statuses on the source
or the conversion statuses no issues
everyone are happy
there are review recommended which means
that there might be some Precision that
you need to be aware of so it's kind of
a warning right you will see an example
a hill so there are like Precision that
you need to take that you need to
understand but it's not really a
conversion issue and the third is action
required which means that DMS were is
not able to convert my uh the objects
and now I need to take care of it and
now let's take an example Cisco Ed
doesn't exist DMS allows you via SQL
editor when he showed you the SQL of the
source and the secret of the data to
actually edit it within DMS again nobody
would need to go to an IDE just within
the product do everything I'm going to
add an extension change it and voila
when I save SQL
the object status change to modify
okay the next step after that would be
okay I'm fine with this schema I want to
add another schema right I said
flexibility I'm going to edit an
additional schema and now I would
convert again and DMS will take
into consideration both of the schemas
right so we're taking into account
everything that's on the source and you
added
and now after I'm doing the converter I
see that everything looks okay I'm
moving to do clouds of possible C I see
that this is how the postgres tree would
look like and now the next step would be
to apply to destination apply means
taking the converted schema and the
converted code and create them on the
destination as always in DMS you can do
tests before that so you can test and
see if the code is executable but in
this case it's a demo let's be wild and
go straight to apply we will choose a
connection profile to the destination we
will check that we have connectivity to
the destination and we can reach it and
again another level of flexibility we
don't
we don't obligate you to choose
everything you can choose specific
objects you want to start with apply
right there are cases that you would
like to work in iterations so choosing
objects applying them
that's it now I'm ready to run a
migration it's that easy see create
migration job within DMS start defining
the migration job
uh you know Name ID prerequisites if you
ever did it you are familiar with that
Define the source connection profile
destination connection profile and the
next step would be to configure which
objects I want to migrate again I might
too I might apply the entire Source but
I want to start with specific object I
want to start with only like two tables
and then add another more tables again
flexibility is a key for DMS I'm
choosing the objects Next Step would be
to run the final test for the migration
to see that everything is working and
that's it the migration is now ready to
run and everyone are happy so to
summarize this is our investment in
product right and as I was saying
product is not enough unfortunately I
wish I could be the product especially
for migration but that's why we have you
know stars like Harry that can help you
with expertise part okay
okay
hold my water for me okay that's what
I'm here for
um yes this car said
um they're
heterogeneous migrations are not
straightforward a lot of times right
particularly if we have a large
landscape databases and
um we're trying to move a complex set of
code that's been written maybe over the
last 20 years right and we're trying to
go from one platform to another which
means the dialect that we speak even
though it's SQL which is relatively
similar across database platforms
there's still all kinds of nuances and
unique things about every database
so
our team there's this team called the
database black belt team I didn't come
up with the name but the idea is that
you know we have a very specialized team
that spent you know almost their
complete careers we still have a little
life left in us but you know very long
time working in the database space and
so we've been through lots of big
migrations lots of uh Performance Tuning
kind of exercises Etc so very deep
expertise in the database but the
combination of a set of people that have
that kind of expertise
combined with the tool that allows us to
do all the stuff that you know was just
described means that we can go to a
large company with a lot of databases
and we can build something that looks
like I hate to say the word but a
migration Factory right how are we going
to come up with a repeatable process
that applies to your specific way that
you've used your database whether that's
you know an Oracle database or a SQL
Server database but basically a legacy
relational database so anyway that's the
the team and what we do and it is to try
to give customers a white glove
experience right we're not a billable
group we're not part of the PSO or
Professional Services organization we're
basically a part of the engineering team
that's designed to work to do two things
one to work closely with Enterprise and
interesting customers that have hard
problems to solve and the second thing
is to work directly with engineering to
help bring back the lessons learned
through those those projects to improve
the tooling and compilerworks is a good
example we've spent a lot of time over
the last year
as we've gone through a couple of
projects making that product better and
better and better and so we're now to
the point where we're very confident
that we can do you know very high level
conversion
automatically right so we're not talking
about 50 or 70 percent or even 80
percent we're talking you know in the
upper
percentages right now that doesn't mean
that if we say we have a 90 conversion
rate that we've eliminated 90 of the
work because as you can imagine the
parts that we're not converting
automatically are the hardest parts so
that that 10 percent may take 20 percent
of the effort right but in general it's
going to be a huge reduction in the
amount of effort that we have to do to
do one of those conversions
so
um just real briefly you guys are all
familiar with what it takes to move
there's two main pieces this is kind of
a schematic diagram there's two main
pieces that I want you guys to know
about one is how do I get started so
there's an assessment tool called
database migration assessment that's
something that our team has built over
the last year and a half and that knows
about our conversion code
so and this may be surprising but this
tool will actually estimate an hourly
estimate of how much time it's going to
take to convert let's say an Oracle
database to postgres
including all the code conversion and
since we know about compiler works and
what it's capable of you know we can
eliminate immediately all the effort
that goes into the the parts that are
automatically converted and uh you know
we're anxious to have as many people as
can private assessment and then try a
project with us to see you know how
accurate those estimates are and improve
those estimates over time but that's one
piece of it second piece is
I wanted to mention and you guys know
this all already the code conversion is
Far and Away the long pole in the tent
right if we're taking again a 20-year
Legacy database application on SQL
server and converting that to postgres
that code conversion is really the
hardest part right and so that's where
we tend to spend a lot of time and where
we tend to get bogged down so again this
code conversion is super important to
what we're doing and so our team part of
what we do is we you know help people
run through that automatic code
conversion but we also will sit down and
go okay this thing is not converted
let's say it's a you know something hard
like bulk collect on Oracle that's a
very difficult thing to translate
automatically so we can take a shot at
it it may not be perfect for an instance
of that and we can sit down and say this
is how we would reproduce that in
postgres and give that Max an example to
the customer to say you know the things
that we've got to do that you know can't
be done automatically this is the
pattern that you would follow to do that
and then the AI thing that Chicago
you know mentioned and showed you this
interface that we have now also allows
one of our guys to sit down and actually
map that out and say this is how I would
rewrite this thing that's not covered in
our deterministic AST based conversion
and let the AI tool attempt to find
every other instance that matches that
pattern and then apply that single shot
or you know double shot kind of learning
to those things right we still are going
to have to go through those and make
sure that those you know are completely
accurate but again it's a you know
reduction by 80 90 percent of the effort
to do that instead of having a manually
go to 500 of these bulk collects and
manually rewrite it does that all make
sense
any questions about that before we go
any further
um I've already talked about the
migration tool so I'll just skip over
this but imagine a fleet-wide assessment
tool that will let you look at a several
hundred or thousands of databases and
then report on those and stack them up
so that you can see uh
see it from different angles but one of
the main ways of doing this is to try to
plan waves of migrations so let's say
you're like a Deutsche Bank that has 10
000 databases that they want to migrate
you know that's not going to happen
overnight right we're going to pick some
set of them hopefully it's uh something
that's on the easier end of the scale
and attack those first then you get the
you know the Kinks out of the process
while we're building this repeatable
process and we're going to go on to the
next one right or for Pilots right if
we're going to try to do not just the
easy ones but maybe pick a medium one
pick an easy one pick a really hard one
and go through that process as part of a
pilot so the tool can do that for us
um and the last thing I'm going to do is
just hand wave a little bit and set up
for Gareth he's going to talk about an
actual project that we did with HSBC so
earlier this year we started a project
that was you know very similar to what
I've described already but uh to build a
migration Factory is what we're looking
to do
for up to 6 000 databases that we wanted
to move and the ideas we're going to
pick three or four or five databases
this project was a combination project
with our Professional Services team and
the black belt team so we're providing
expertise to help get over the hump but
the Professional Services team is the
guys that are there to really build the
migration Factory and turn that over to
HSBC of course the HSBC application
teams are you know very heavily involved
in this process and so is the
engineering team on the DMS side this
was actually done while we were in
private preview it wasn't even a a ga
product at the time we started it
so again right team right knowledge
right tools you know basically that
combination is is what we're trying to
provide all right and with that I'll
turn it over to Gareth and let him talk
about you know the really important part
which is how did this thing play out
with uh with a real customer
thanks thank you
yeah so
I think my angle on this is I like the
word migration Factory by the way I
think it's a good idea it's a good
concept I think my angle on this and put
a preamp put a preamble first of all
so HSBC very complicated Global
organization from the very large
shipping of transaction of trade around
around the world number one trade Bank
we can see there are 800 billion dollars
worth of transactions
on an annual basis requires an awful lot
of processing behind the scenes requires
those six thousand Oracle databases Gary
mentioned behind the scenes a lot of
complexity everywhere so we have the
largest of the largest of scale they
have the smallest of the smallest the
bottom left
is a mobile app built natively on Google
using only native database and contain
the technology
so we like to have the worst and the
worst we'd like to have the best and the
best but ultimately we need to shift
from one to the other and as Shaka said
as Kerry said we need a repeatable
trustworthy process
this is part of a wider Journey that
that we're on as an organization a lot
of this is very familiar to you
how do we get products to Market quicker
for our customers which is probably some
of you in the room you know our Global
footprint of retail commercial products
trade products digital banking apps
everywhere how do we get products to
Market quicker
we know we cannot do that on our own
we'd be foolish enough you know we've
we're entrusted with your money not with
your technology that's what we trust
these guys for and some of you in the
room you know we trust Google for their
technology hopefully
three of you trust those with your money
that's that's the partnership we're
trying to move to here
in order to do that it's got to be
resilient it's got to be secure it's got
to be as frictionless as possible
and again it's got to be it's going to
have that scale to I can't emphasize
enough the scale problems we have as a
global organization
so the partnership with Google started
five years ago
um
right on the cusp of when Google were
trying to sort of I think break into the
Enterprise customer and consumer Market
nobody's ever going to question the
scale the the volume of the Google apps
the the one you know the nine apps that
serve over one billion customers each
we're not going to compete with that
but what Google had to learn very
quickly is how do you work with an
Enterprise Financial Services client how
do you work with an Enterprise
Automotive client how do you work with
an Enterprise energies client
that operates in 50 60 80 100 countries
with regulated markets you know we have
400 Regulators we have to satisfy on an
annual basis who want to know where
their customers money is at any one time
so the partnership with Google was about
building their products set enhancing it
to meet the rigor of a financial
services organization but enabling us to
grow our digital footprint enabling us
to expand into technology
that we couldn't have done on our own we
couldn't have released new products to
Market we couldn't have gotten more
secure we couldn't have scaled without
this partnership with Google
so I usually only have one slide for
this presentation and this is the one
slide
on that partnership on that scale
constant Tech evolution
the one problem I have is standing still
standing still as a large company with
thousands of databases
thousands of applications is standing
still cost me money it cost me a lot of
money
just keeping the lights on costs our
organization an awful lot of money yeah
I I won't go into the details but
just keeping an application current
keeping it free from vulnerabilities we
talked about log4j this morning
I wish it took any I wish it took us
only a week to tackle log for Jay yeah
we're still tackling the remnants of it
now because we couldn't discover
everything was we couldn't get to every
server out there we couldn't get to
every database service out there just to
look at our exposure
because we don't have the tools we don't
have the technology and we're fighting
years and years of legacy
again really resonating to the to this
morning's keynote we are fighting with
Years of Legacy
but I'll repeat what we said this
morning Legacy is good
Legacy is where your money is stored so
Legacy has to be very good
but the challenge still is it cost us
money to stand still we need to
accelerate our technology migration
we can build new stuff on cloud to meet
new regulations to meet new mobile
propositions to
to get the new funky things out there
but what about the rest of our
technology
I think that's what started our journey
to a factory
it's not a it's not a an old concept
sorry it's not a New Concept it's been
around for a long time you know the the
re-host free platform re-architect
but for us the factory is making it a
compelling reason for our application
teams our application owners to move to
a new technology
well it costs them an awful lot of money
to stand still it costs them even more
money to do something to change their
application it costs them more money and
it costs them downtime to change their
application they haven't got that so
we've got to give them a compelling
reason to move
and that's what and that's why we came
up with the idea for the migration
Factory
the challenge is that graph on the on
the top right of the screen
you can see a couple of lines that
disappear off into the sunset that's the
the top one really is the line of do
nothing and your cost base increases
year on year if you do not touch that
that Oracle database that sci base
database a db2 database and it grows and
you have to keep it running you have to
keep it patch free you have to upgrade
the infrastructure underneath you have
to keep it current to latest versions
that line just keeps going up and up and
up
you've not done anything to improve the
functionality and feature of that you
just kept the lights on
and then you can see the bit of red
shading at the bottom of that of that
table
that's the size of the opportunity that
we're trying to grab hold of from a
dollar perspective and the longer this
goes out the opportunity gets greater
but the cost gets even further away from
us
so what we're trying to do is come up
with a way to stop that line growing and
growing and growing and to realize the
opportunity of transforming and
modernizing our services
I think that's what really kicked off
the need to say to Google guys we're all
in with you but we need a way to get
from A to B we need a repeatable process
we need a hands-off keys process
we need a process we can audit a process
we can log a process we can scale
and that's what started the journey with
the database migration service we have a
clear intent
to move
some if not all of those six thousand
Oracle databases and modernize our
infrastructure entirely
but we know this is only the start of
the journey
the Oracle to postgres will only be the
very start of the journey for us
we're very excited to to work to work
with these guys on Oracle to alloy
hopefully alloy only as well because we
know the scale that we have around
Oracle and those global instances can
only be met by some of the the more
scalable robust services from Google
so all of that all of this one slide
really encapsulates our modernization
journey and the opportunity that if we
don't take we miss the costs keep going
away the estate keeps getting bigger
I'll think on that
no it really is the you know I really
don't mind doing the cell here on your
guys behalf is the partnership we've
chosen you know a few of my engineering
team in in Hong Kong and London
team they just got together and worked
as a virtual team yeah those are the
problem statements here's our complexity
here's a way of tackling through with it
with the expertise here are the products
available to you
I think without that I think we wouldn't
have got where we are today we certainly
wouldn't have got the opportunity now to
start moving those databases
I think that all comes back to I think
my one sort of when I finish on this is
it's not an unfamiliar message to any of
you you know without the products and
services in place we cannot make it a
compelling reason
to go to our business owners our finance
owners our application teams and say
come on guys there's no reason why you
should not be modernizing and migrating
your services
I think chakra that's it yeah over to
you for questions
thank you so
you know I cannot be more fortunate than
having you know HSBC and Gareth what is
the customer and as a partner I think
like the entire story is like music for
my ears and we're really happy to
continue that with ledb rudb Omni so I
hope that you're now convinced that
database migrations is a complex Pro
problem but we got you covered in Google
cloud and with our organization you can
get started today everything that
representative here is GAO available for
in preview you can just go to the
console start using it we have the
documentation and there are multiple
sign up forms both in the DMS site and
in the console
just send us a sign up or give us your
email and I personally will contact you
[Applause]